you
what is chemistry
well remembering our chemistry class
it's the periodic table titrations
equilibrium reactions and ionic bonds
not perhaps the most engaging topics at
first sight and if you've ever been
bored staring at reaction mechanisms
you're in good company after my junior
year in college I worked in a laboratory
and went the entire summer not getting
one experiment to succeed when I got to
college I found chemistry as taught at
Harvard was so awful that I resolved
never had touch in chemistry any more
Roger Tsien and Martin Chalfie were
awarded the Nobel Prize in Chemistry in
2008 for their contributions to humanity
how do you get from an adverse intested
in chemistry to a chemical contribution
to humanity the keys that chemistry is
so much more all-embracing than first
encountered in the textbooks and the lab
chemistry is so insidious I would say
that you don't notice it off we are
sitting here and I think probably most
of what we are wearing is chemistry
hidden you don't see it in most cases
that's one of the problems chemistry is
not on the forefront you know but it's
always there chemistry is that massive
part of physics that pertains to the
world we live in in general people who
forgotten or not aware of how important
chemistry is to almost every aspect of
their life they don't even think that
when they go to the dentist the
anesthetic that makes their sort of
visit pain free and bearable is
chemistry
on the rare occasions when chemistry
does get any attention it's usually
because of some industrial accident or
perceived threat from contaminants in
our food it must have to do with
people's experience of chemistry at
school you know smelly but chemistry
also lies at the heart of so many other
aspects of daily life whether it's a
question of how to remove carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere or what we can do to
make computers process information even
faster chemistry is the set of tools we
need to find the answer but while
studying the processes of chemistry when
your eyes are swimming with formulas
it's easy to forget that most of what
scientists define as chemistry has a
direct connection with the world
today's chemistry is a very broad field
there are chemists who work on what we
would call material science they try to
create new materials for building things
but they can also be used for example
for tissue replacements for an
artificial knee or an you know
artificial hip other chemists have been
awarded the prize for studying
atmospheric chemistry which has great
importance in understanding climate
change and the ozone hole how the
production of carbon dioxide can lead to
global warming in the last 50 years
there's been a lot of progress in sort
of the core synthesis aspects of
chemistry
but at the same time much of chemistry
is now directed towards problems in
biology since the Industrial Revolution
chemists have been transforming the
material world around us now as well as
working on solutions to the energy
crisis global warming and advances in
electronics they are increasingly
turning their sights to life itself our
best hope of applying physical
principles after the world around us is
at the level of chemistry our best hope
of understanding the biological organism
and ultimately the form and function of
the human body is at the level of
chemistry that's what we are we're a
test room in which a huge number of
complex chemical reactions are taking
place you know visitors are also tools
of learning and at the end of the day
these are aberrations in chemical
reactions in processes biochemical
processes that are occurring in our body
this is one of the beauties of chemistry
all the principles you learn in class
the tools you can apply to help
understand everything around you redox
reactions and the laws of thermodynamics
all work in the same way whether within
an enzyme in a human brain or in a
beaker on a lab bench the excitement of
chemistry is still there in what in the
traditional core areas but now equally
there's excitement in chemistry out on
the edges one looks at the advances in
condensed matter physics of making
semiconductors of making solar cells
these are all chemistry and that's at
the core of chemistry while physicists
try for the perfect description of the
subatomic universe or biologists
endeavor to piece together the workings
of life it's chemistry that holds the
power to make something of it to
describe the atomic clockwork of our
world and then see just what we can do
with it I think today more than ever
before chemistry is an over
chainsaw is the overarching sounds or in
some ways the underpinning science in
physics we try to understand the world
around us
the chemistry is unique in that it
creates new materials new items do new
medicines useful mankind and make our
lives better chemistry is greater than
it first appears it forms the basis of
all of our knowledge of fields as
diverse as genetics solar energy and
nanotechnology
and it equips the curious with a means
to explore our world further chemistry
is really the queen of the sciences
chemistry is the common ground for all
scientific investigation if there is any
one subject than an educated person
should know in the world that his
chemistry
you